Until now, we have seen data
that are structured, numerical,
or categorical.
On the other hand, tweets
are loosely structured.
They are often textual.
They have poor
spelling, often contain
non-traditional grammar,
and they are multilingual.
In this example here,
we see two examples
of this aspect of tweets.
We have also discussed why
people care about textual data.
A key question, however, is
how to handle this information,
including in the tweets.
Humans cannot, of course, keep
up with internet-scale volumes
of data as there are about
half a billion tweets per day.
Even at the small
scale, the cost and time
required to process this
is of course prohibitive.
How can computers help?
The field that addresses how
computers understand text
is called Natural
Language Processing.
The goal is to understand
and derive meaning
from human language.
In 1950, Alan Turing, a major
computer scientist of the era,
proposed a test of
machine intelligence.
That the computer program
passes it if it can take part
in a real-time conversation and
cannot be distinguished from
a human.
Let's discuss briefly the
history of Natural Language
Processing.
There has been some
progress-- for example,
the "chatterbot" ELIZA.
The initial focus has been
on understanding grammar.
Later, the focus shifted towards
statistical, machine learning
techniques that learn
from large bodies of text.
Today, there are modern versions
of these Natural Language
Processing.
Apple is using Siri, and
Google is using Google Now.
Why is it hard?
Let us give you an example.
Suppose we say the phrase,
I put my bag in the car.
Is it large and blue?
The question is, does
the "it" refer to the bag
or the "it" refers to car?
The context is often important.
Humans use homonyms,
metaphors, often sarcasm.
In this lecture, we'll see
how can build analytics models
using text as our data.